this was the biggest weekend yet for
valor and esports
and honestly it gave me incredible hope
for the future of this esport
listen not everything about it was
perfect
but if the action that we saw and the
production that was put on to support it
is any indication the future of valor
and esports looks bright
unless you're a g2 esports fan
my snow shovel is easily accessible and
you know what that means
it's time for the score esports awards
we'll be streaming
live this friday at 5 p.m on twitch and
youtube
and i'm gonna be there so why not come
hang out watch us hand out a bunch of
sweet awards
personally i'm hoping that the himbo
himself hassan
can take home some hardware see you
there so if you were living under a rock
this weekend
you might not have heard about valrant's
first strike regional finals
the esports first major event in the
spotlight
was north america of course and hundreds
of thousands of fans were treated to an
absolute gem of a tournament
in some admittedly trying times the
production quality was great
the on-air talent was stacked and of
course
the games themselves were exciting but
at the end of it all
it was hundred thieves that took home
the glory
tsm there's only two players left
there's a two versus four for tsm they
have to find a way out of the situation
but it's getting worse
and worse and who better than hiko to
look to seal the deal here
in this grand finals as carlos tries he
does all that he can but it's simply not
enough against a hundred thieves
a hundred thieves they've done it they
are your first strike
north america champions
[Music]
now for an event that was played
remotely
in unusual circumstances and was the
first
truly massive event of the game's
history
i honestly think they did a pretty good
job this event
had a lot to like we're talking about a
game that's competing against
counter-strike
and they're holding the event in the
middle of a pandemic so
if you're riot this is a big win fans
seem to agree
as over 300 000 peak concurrent viewers
tuned in to watch the na streams and
yeah
i said streams because riot allowed
select personalities like myth and ninja
to restream the games to their own
channels
where they did some pretty big numbers
this strategy of allowing streamers to
restream competitive matches
isn't new for riot but it's good to see
it continue invalid
especially because myth stream gave us
one of the best moments of the night
as he tried to inspire a tsm squad
that was down 0-2 it is our time
to ascend from the depths and give it
everything we [ __ ] got other esports
communities like rainbow six siege
started talking about how letting
streamers restream competitive matches
could help their own esport and in
counter-strike
the game that valorent most directly
competes with
both esl and dreamhack have so far
not allowed community streams shroud
even said that
he would have been streaming for a
strike if not for the fact that his wow
classic guild was
trying to kill a 14 year old raid boss
you can do it you can do it
it's only sony
while we don't know the exact
requirements or selection process for
riot's community streams
it's something that i hope continues
especially for
other regions like europe it helps to
bring in new viewers but
also to build a community that actually
watches the competitive side of the game
something that will help it remain
popular even as the game's player base
continues to expand
but back to the results in north america
hundred thieves had to answer a very
pressing question
how would their new look roster
completed about two months ago
fair against na's best before this
change the roster had struggled but it
sure looks like when you have the
experience of
hiko nitro and steel and you pair that
with young guns like
dicey and osna you can beat the rest of
n.a valorant
it will be cool to see if this team
continues to let
dicey and osna off the leash a little
bit
it definitely worked this weekend and it
was exciting to watch
lassana is the trip off the rocket is
the fourth kill
monstrous performance there on short a
looking
for the last player what a time to bust
out the best
showstopper we've seen in months the
triple frag
this early into the round grand finals
and the ace
for arsenal can you believe it super
star
duelist and like not only did asana do
that but he did it in what's probably
the most important match of his life
cold dude i can't wait to learn more
about this killer and listen if you're a
tsm fan
even though they lost in grand finals
they were still able to prove themselves
against both renegades and team envy
honestly the most disappointing part of
the tournament might just be that
tsm and sentinels weren't able to sort
that whole thing out sentinels played a
very good match against faze clan
but they lost a close set against
hundred thieves where sinatra just
wasn't able to make the difference but
na isn't the only region in valorant
and if you thought it was that's okay
most of the hype was pointed at it and i
forgive you this time
in europe we saw the incredibly hyped g2
esports roster
fail to make grand finals where team
heretics triumphed over
sumn fc heretics captain lowell
who has plenty of counter-strike
experience
was named mvp in combination
a 1v3 it falls to pieces heretics the
titan slayers
took down liquid took down g2
and now they take the crown heretics are
your valor and
first strike european champion heretics
destroyed both
liquid and g2 esports on the way to
their grand finals win
that's great for team heretics but if
you're a g2 esports fan
it's probably a bit of a disappointment
to see them go out like that
the viewership for europe was just over
a third of na's peak which
is another potential future issue
counter-strike is
king in europe at least for now and it
will be interesting to see if that
changes anytime soon
so i guess my point is this right now
in north america and europe the best
teams have a substantial
background in counter-strike maybe
that's not surprising given the
similarities between the two games but
something to keep in mind for the future
but more than just na and europe
riot held first strike regional
tournaments this past weekend for
the cis region turkey japan
korea oceania asia pacific and brazil
some of them like korea brazil and japan
were even held offline and that brings
me to my last point
where exactly do we go from here because
the hunger for international competition
is only going to grow
from this point but if things continue
as they have and even if we see
widespread vaccinations soon it seems
like it's going to be a little while
before
fans get the faded eu n a match up
that they're desperately hoping for not
to mention
other exciting regions that fans want to
see like brazil
the cis region or korea plus i think
valorent will want to avoid some of the
mistakes i personally saw
from overwatch's early years which was a
lot of initial hype
that eventually sort of became squashed
by a league announcement that was
so far in the future that it made
current competitions seem
less exciting listen not everybody loves
valerian
our own demetri pascaluda shared his
opinion
on the game in a recent video look
everything about riot's announcement
seems great as long as third party
tournaments are permitted to run on the
side
and the scene is allowed to grow
organically i have zero issues with
their roadmap
the problem is that none of this changes
the fact that in my opinion
and this is just that my opinion
valorent continues to just not be a very
good game
but if you're a fan of valorant the good
news is that
at least in my opinion this was an
excellent
starting point a true first strike
for the scene
listen my snow shovel is easily
accessible so
you know what that means it's time for
the score esports awards
we'll be streaming live this friday at 5
p.m
on twitch and youtube and i'm gonna be
there
so why not show up and ask me about my
cat the walls are closing in
and the other night my winston pillow
talked to me
and told me about a biblical prophecy
involving flexing on people with yachts
and uh things are
things are bleak here uh definitely send
some help
definitely send some help why
why he's ripped but
look at this he shred like a cheese
grater